this video is brought to you by Dragon
City hey wisecrack jared here and today
we're talking about the smart and
stylish JRPG that lets you
simultaneously date your high school
teacher your middle school age
stepsister and an alcoholic lois lane
persona 5 for those of you who've never
played persona 5 we recommend pausing
this video and playing through the 120
hour campaign but if you don't have that
much time we'll summarize it for you the
persona series is basically what you get
if a group of otaku made a pokemon
clones set in the world of inside-out
he's been half the game in a high school
social management simulator and the
other half is a superhero gentleman
thief that enters people's cognitions in
order to catch them all albeit instead
of Pikachu's you're nabbing mythological
monsters gods heroes historical figures
and characters from literature including
whatever the hell this is going by the
codenamed Joker you slowly assemble a
crew called the phantom thieves of
hearts to heist the innermost desires
from the most powerful and corrupt
adults in society so let's look at
whether the aspects of persona which
people praised so often are actually
deep or dumb spoilers ahead for the
original game but not for the expanded
version persona 5 royal which won't be
stateside until the end of march before
we get into it I want to give a shout
out to Dragon City a mobile RPG
available on iOS and Android Dragon city
is like a hero collector but instead of
heroes you collect dragons generate gold
to buy food and level up your dragons
for battle there are hundreds of very
cute and very ferocious dragons hidden
in Dragon City for you to collect I
recently found the binge dragon my
personal favorite the movie fanatic
dragon and a serial killer dragon
there's even a poo dragon you can also
breed different species to complete your
collection I bread my binge dragon with
my movie fanatic dragon and they had a
neon dragon collect as many dragons as
you can and use them in battle but more
on that later you can download the game
for free using the link in the
description and now back to the show
part 1 union psychology Karl Yune was
the founder of analytical psychology
just as his colleague Sigmund Freud
invented an entire vocabulary for
psychoanalysis who coined terms like
archetype shadow persona
and the collective unconscious and the
series sites its Union influences
explicitly in persona 4 golden you can
unlock new episodes of mr. e da Gama's
TV classroom which are straight-up
lectures about Jungian psychology but
the primary place you encounter these
Union terms is during the combat
sections when our regular high schoolers
enter the Metaverse they transform into
personas that are dramatizations of the
Union concept much in the same way as
joy and anger and inside out our
dramatizations of emotions really the
whole world of persona is a
dramatization of Jung's ideas about the
human psyche take the meta verse a world
created by human cognition that the
phantom thieves are capable of entering
the meta versus representative of all
psychological activity collective and
individual conscious and unconscious
some parts called palaces represent an
individual's mental activity
specifically their distorted perspective
of a place in the real world
take the girls volleyball coach kkoma
schita he's got such a high opinion of
his status that youjin Academy that he
envisions it as a castle ruled by him as
its king other parts such as mementos
are how society as a whole sees the
world around it and given the deep
cynicism of the day it's not a pleasant
place this shared psychic space of
society along with the sea of souls from
which all shadows and personas emerge
our dramatizations of a union concept
called the collective unconscious it's
those parts of the mind that we
inherited from our most remote ancestors
like fight or flight but it also
includes what you described as
pre-existent forms the archetypes which
give definite form to certain psychic
contents of the innumerable archetypes
within the collective unconscious um
considered for to be primordial the most
basic and universal images among which
are the persona and the shadow personas
are social masks that the ego chooses to
wear Ewing himself described them as
designed on the one hand to make a
definite impression upon others and on
the other to conceal the true nature of
the individual in Latin persona refers
to the masks worn by actors and in the
game whenever they enter the men averse
the phantom thieves quite literally wear
their personas as masks / young the
thieves personas are how they want
society to see them and how they want to
see themselves take on who is
apprehensive about her beauty because it
draws on one
attention when her persona awakens it's
as Carmen from the famous opera a fierce
femme fatale who uses her penchant for
seduction to deadly effect effectively
this transforms ons appearance from a
liability into a strength another union
term is shadow or these psychological
aspects which the conscious self is
unaware of and would rather not
acknowledge in the game shadows serve as
the enemies most are generic but the
bosses are shadows specific to certain
characters but the game designers didn't
just look too young for their world
building his ideas are equally
represented in the gameplay mechanics as
well the way shadows and personas are
grouped reflects Young's concept of
archetypes / young the term archetype is
often misunderstood as meaning certain
definite mythological images or motifs
but the archetype is a tendency to form
such representations of a motif
representations that can vary a great
deal in detail without losing their
basic pattern so the personas aren't
themselves part of the collective
unconscious that everyone inherits no
one is born with the idea of Odin in
their head but they do have part of
their mental space sequestered off for
the idea of senex a generic wise old man
and this idea is given form through
characters such as Odin Baal and both
who are all grouped together in the
games organization to capture a shadow
Joker must find some point of
commonality with it that is he must
recognize it as being part of himself
similarly confronting and recognizing
one's own shadows is a distinctive
aspect of Jung's process of
individuation once he's moved it from
the dark parts of his psyche into the
light of consciousness Joker can then
equip the shadow as a persona but
there's another game play used for
personas that better exemplifies the
Union concept as Joker converses with
important people called confidants his
bond with them strengthens each of these
has a particular archetype that most
closely exemplifies their personality by
equipping a persona belonging to the
same archetype before conversing with a
confidant Joker forges his friendship
with them faster since they're
recognizing something of themselves in
him this is reflective of Jung's idea
that we wear different personas for
different people choosing to share one
side of ourselves with friends another
with family and another with coworkers
even more Jungian is the phantom thieves
entire modus operandi they enter into
their mark psyche and steal whatever it
is
the individual treasures so much that
it's twisted their desires and distorted
their perception of reality and always
end up confronting the targets shadow
after this treasure is stolen and the
shadow defeated the individual undergoes
a dramatic change of personality this
can be seen as akin to psychotherapy
despite stylizing themselves as thieves
their goal is to effect psychological
and moral improvement in the subject
albeit less talking on a couch to defeat
inner demons and more slashing them with
samurai swords given all this the
consonants between the world-building
story and the gameplay mechanics all
around this one unifying motif and we've
absolutely got to give personas use of
Jungian psychology a certified deep part
too esoteric Tarot the game continues
its union motifs with the use of Tarot
to organize elements such as shadows
personas and confidants according to the
archetypes found in the cards Ewing
himself acknowledged the Tarot as
containing compelling archetypal imagery
he wrote it also seems as if a set of
pictures in the tarot cards were
distantly descended from the archetypes
of transformation Tarot began back in
the 15th century as a deck for playing
card games in addition to the
traditional four suits aka the Minor
Arcana it included 22 trump cards the
Major Arcana it wasn't until the late
18th century that it began to be used
for occult purposes of which you're
probably most familiar with cartomancy
or divining the future by drawing cards
but apart from fortune teller the Tarot
was also incorporated into occult
schools of thoughts with each card
taking on multitudes of media such as
the Major Arcana corresponding to one of
the 22 letters of the Hebrew alphabet
and 22 paths of the Kabbalah story of
life or the force due to the Minor
Arcana corresponding to the four
classical elements and the four letters
of the Tetragrammaton the use of the
Tarot as a set of symbols became known
as esoteric Tarot to distinguish it from
its primary purpose as playing cards the
order of the Major Arcana also tells a
story known as the fool's journey that
is seen as both the story of each
individual soul and the history of the
universe as a whole persona phibes most
successful application of esoteric Tarot
is in structuring its confidants system
around the fool's journey
Joker's own journey begins when he meets
Igor B contri not associated with Arcana
zero LaMotte aka
The Fool in esoteric Tarot the fool is
at the first step on a path towards
self-realization with that path taking
him through these subsequent cards of
the Major Arcana this is reflected in
Joker's need to maximize his rank with
all of his confidants each of whom is
explicitly linked to one of the Major
Arcana and whose own side story teaches
Joker the lessons of their associated
card it's not enough for him to simply
beat the final boss like the fool he is
to achieve enlightenment in the way
prescribed by esoteric Tarot in order to
unlock the game's true ending which
Arcana the confidence belonged to often
reflects the role they play in the
narrative occasionally the game makes a
particularly appropriate connection
regarding what Arcana a character
belongs to and which persona they
manifest Mikoto's Arcana is lapa pest
traditionally associated with the
legendary Pope Joan the very same as
Makoto's initial persona Yoanna but more
often the game makes a surface level
association between the characters
Arcana and their personality ons Arcana
Isla Maru the lovers primarily because
she is the first love interest available
in the game and the object of desire to
multiple male characters Futaba of let
our meat literally hermits herself away
in her room
Chihaya of the rue de for toon is
herself a tarot reading fortune-teller
and Tate to kemi's work in the medical
field places her in proximity to death
pers being the card with no name AKA la
mort this last one reveals how alice's
understanding of esoteric Tarot can be a
bit shallow as the 13th Arcana is
associated not with literal death but is
rather symbolic of endings and change in
some cases the surface level connections
come at the cost of a deeper one paruz
final persona Astarte of the empress
Arcana is specifically called the Queen
of Heaven in the Bible this naturally
compares her with Mary whom the
Catholics affirmed as the Regina Coeli
the Queen of Heaven however Arthur
Edward wait who co-created the most
famous esoteric tarot deck contrast the
Empress with Mary as Queen of Heaven
saying the Empress is associated with
Mary only as refugee impecca forum the
refuge of sinners and an earthly Garden
of Eden according to him the Empress is
very specifically not a heavenly figure
the game gets it backwards this is
hardly nitpicking esoteric Tarot is
interesting specifically because it's
imagery and structure invites
systemization with diverse schools of
thought like the Jewish Kabbalah and the
Catholic corporis doctrine in getting
the meanings mixed up personified
doesn't quite justify structuring its
systems around the Tarot the game is
obviously interested in Tarot for its
esoteric associations as well as its
union ones but fails to engage with the
esotericism in any real meaningful ways
the fact that the game follows the Tarot
of Marseille an older deck more
associated with card games rather than
the rider-waite deck which was
specifically constructed to convey
esoteric symbolism certainly evidence is
this while the fools journey of the
confidence system and one or two of the
characters associated Arcana are
somewhat deep for the most part persona
fives use of Tarot is kind of dumb part
3 ethical systems and moral realism but
persona 5 is also structured to make a
moral argument the story is built around
high stting a few major palaces parts of
the Metaverse that have been warped by
the distorted perception of a sinful
individual because the phantom thieves
suck at sneaking all of their high
school mates in a climactic boss battle
against the palaces owners or at least
their shadow these big bads are based on
the seven deadly sins with each one of
the palaces explicitly named after one
of the vices number one Camus Tschida
like many dudes who coach high school
girls athletics is pervy his palace is
the castle of lust inside it his shadow
looks like Asmodeus who according to
theologian Peter bins filled is the
Prince of Hell associated with lust to
Mathura Mei is an artist that uses other
people's works to promote his own Fame
so his palace is the museum of vanity
three Kaneshiro is a corpulent crime
boss who hungers for more and more money
from those he extorts that may sound
like greed but his palace is the bank of
gluttony a theme reinforced not only by
his rotundity but by the Beelzebub like
appearance of his shadow that being the
demon bins filled connected to gluttony
for futaba's anger at herself for
apparently causing her mother's death
results in her palace being the pyramid
of wrath five-oh Gomorrah is a
businessman who envisions his employees
as robots existing only to labor for him
his palace being the spaceship of grief
he is interested in money solely but
wealth in all its various expressions ie
mom
so it's appropriate that the same demon
is also the name of his shadow again
following bins fields list six nojima is
a prosecutor who's so envious of her
colleagues win records that she's
willing to do anything to get a
conviction her palace is the casino of
envy for the house always wins and her
shadow her bins filled is Leviathan
seven cheeto is a politician who when he
tried to force himself on a woman and
Joker saved her had Joker charged with
assault his Express aim as Prime
Minister is to screw over the unwashed
masses while profiting his chosen few
you know a typical politician his palace
is the cruiser of pride traditionally
the deadliest sins eight humanity as a
whole is responsible for such
intellectual and moral laziness that
they collectively have a distorted
perception of reality leading to the
public palace known as momentos aka the
prison of sloth and no we didn't forget
how to count the seven deadly sins have
as their antecedent the monk Evagrius
Ponte kisses eight evil thoughts and
tell Pope Gregory the first subsumes
vainglory under pride the ordering of
the villains appearances confirms
roughly to the severity of the sins per
traditional Catholic understanding this
has seen most vividly in Dante's
Purgatorio Dante's ordering was lust
gluttony avarice sloth wrath Envy pride
this is essentially the same as the
order of the palaces in persona with one
important difference persona moves sloth
in the final slot suggesting that sloth
is properly the deadliest sin in
addition to the inherent evil of their
signature sin the villains are also
ordered with respect to their sphere of
influence with greater influence
allowing for a greater severity to their
transgressions whereas kama Shiva's
influence is limited only to shuji an
academy Madara may has influence over
the entire art community can a shiro
over a wide swath of the criminal
underworld and Okamura and Shido on a
national stage as captains of business
and politics respectively the final boss
is yalda Bao's a Gnostic name for the
creator of the world because it wouldn't
be a proper JRPG if you didn't kill God
at the end and being God his influence
extends over the whole of humanity the
name yaldabaoth comes from the
apocryphon of John now the Archon who is
weak has three names
the first is yelled Aveo the second is
sockless and
third is Samael this connects Yalda
bayaud with the penultimate boss Shido
whose shadow is Samael and joker himself
as sockless means fool a reference back
to Joker being on the fool's journey
now the narrative progresses in one
other interesting way the villains are
ordered roughly according to which
system of ethics they're supposed to
Authority derives from kimochi de and
Madara may are both adults in positions
of authority preying on high schoolers ,
Tschida by hitting on literal jailbait
and Madara may by stealing his students
artwork
neither's actions align with any ethical
theory both simply presumed that age
gives them natural Authority this is
pretty much the first ethical framework
any individual operates under to listen
to those older than us can a shiro
self-loathing and his own perceived
weakness leads him to operate under the
theory that might makes right and to
build a criminal enterprise to
compensate all of these are what
psychologist Lawrence Kohlberg in his
stages of moral development categorized
as preconventional such moral attitudes
are marked by their deference to
superior power or prestige as opposed to
principled moral reasonings
alternatively as a prosecutor signee
Jima occupies Kohlberg's fourth stage of
moral development a conventional
category in which the law itself is the
foundation for morality whether or not
the law is actually just Shido and yalda
bails represent Kohlberg's post
conventional stages of moral development
as Prime Minister
Cheetos Authority derives from the
consent of the governed this is culverts
fifth stage in which laws are malleable
based on the will of the masses
Kohlberg's sixth stage is that of
universal ethical principles right and
wrong are the same for all people at all
places at all times regardless of
man-made laws one permutation of a
universal ethical principle is divine
command theory the idea that the
foundation of morality is whatever God
says is right or wrong as a stand-in for
God
Elda bail is representative of this type
of moral reasoning in fighting all B's
foes the Phantom thieves are not merely
opposing the deadly sins themselves but
also the various ethical frameworks to
which society has subscribed and we
think this is why the structure of the
game imputes sloth as the deadliest sin
of all humanity sloth has made it
intellectually and morally lazy
humanity has abdicated the hard work of
moral decision-making to these various
ethical systems and the even harder work
of actually being morally active members
of society to those few individuals
running the various spheres of influence
and unfortunately they've not been
particularly moral the thieves while far
from being immoral or amoral don't
neatly conform their ethical
hand-wringing to any prescribed ethical
theories this is what differentiates
them from the slothfulness of the masses
under the sway of Yalda BeOS throughout
all the heists cumulative leave the
thieves go through an ethical process
that French philosopher Jacques Derrida
described as undecidability essentially
all moral decisions come down to
deciding between taking actions based on
a moral framework or rejecting those
actions for any reason ranging from not
feeling like it to distrust for the
moral frameworks at play for instance
the thieves consistently reject the
justifications for laws that sign iijima
blindly enforces and even when the rules
seem to have a foundation such as
Cheetos Democratic mandate or yelled
obey of divine commands such rote
formulae won't necessarily apply to
individual circumstances thus according
to Derrida all a moral decision-making
is undecidable by proscribed ways of
thinking a decision that did not go
through the ordeal of the undecidable
would not be a free decision it would
only be the programmable application or
unfolding of a calculable process only
by exerting great moral and intellectual
effort by continually undergoing Garrity
and undecidability time and again
throughout their careers our our heroes
able to avoid the deadly sin of sloth
but while the Phantom phoebs avoided
slothfulness themselves by being the
only ones to take on these various
systems they become a moral crutch who
everyone else outsources their
decision-making to so whether it's the
thieves or psy or Shido the end result
is the same this is why y'all debate
remains as powerful as ever even after
she toes defeated at first this seems to
be an example of the games mechanics
coming into conflict with its narrative
the story is saying that society itself
has to overcome its moral lethargy but
by virtue of being a game that can only
come about by decisions you as the
player make the NPC's never make a real
choice and continue to a
avoid confronting undecidability and
continue being slothful hiding the true
ending behind maxing out all the
confidants is a smart solution to this
problem that is to say that in the true
ending all the NPC's who help with the
final victory have gone through the same
ethical challenge as the phantom thieves
despite challenging such ethical
frameworks by framing the decision to
destroy yalda veiled as unambiguously
right persona 5 ultimately affirms moral
realism even if no one epic 'el system
can fully articulate what makes a good
right and evil wrong good and evil are
very much real it condemns the moral
nihilism of the game spoil Goro akechi
this is a departure from Derrida who
rejects the notion that we're ever
approaching a true ethics and claims
undecidability is the whole of the
matter but the game says it's only a
step toward the truth of right and wrong
thankfully the game is much more clear
than real life and assuring that you did
the right thing mainly by rewarding you
with an anime waifu on valentine's day
so for balancing the complication of
ethical systems with an affirmation of
moral realism and giving as extensive
and examination of moral wrongdoing as
dante persona 5 is as deep as the ninth
circle of hell but tell us what you
think wisecrack are being too much like
fortune tellers reading too much into
what's just not there or did we
successfully infiltrate your cognition
and force a change of heart as to how
you feel about persona 5 let us know in
the comments below
big shout out to all our awesome patrons
don't forget to subscribe and before you
go I want to give one last shout out to
Dragon City once you have a collection
of dragons you can take them to battle
and collect gold and exp here you can
see me using food to level up my movie
fanatic dragon and after some training
you should definitely be able to win
some battles the game also offers
different PvP modes where you can take
your favorite dragons and fight in the
leagues or in the arena there are new
events every week like match 3 puzzles
and mazes
so start growing your dragon collection
and go to battle today hit the link in
the description to download the game for
free and as always thanks for watching
guys
peace
[Music]